you know when jesus went to a fig tree
yeah yes
if if the father was inside him yeah
okay if the father was inside him
jesus went across and said there's figs
right
when he went there what did he find did
he find figs no he sees there were no
effects on the truth
there was no things in the trees right
so if god if jesus is god
did he lie like did he did he not know
that when i go
there he's not feeling do you want to
know the answer to that question yes
please
okay the fig tree yeah in the bible
is a parable of israel the nation of
israel
he actually talks elsewhere about the
fig and the olive
and so on and so forth so what jesus is
saying
when he sees the fig tree it's basically
saying he saw no
fruit coming from the nation of israel
from the political nation well does that
say that in the bible it's a political
nation
that's what he was saying he's saying
it's a parallel it was a parable i know
but does it say
this tree is uh the nation of israel may
no fruit ever come from you again
yes but he's on about the tree he's not
about the elsewhere
jesus said not elsewhere no well i'm
just telling you i said do you want to
know the answer
i'm giving you the answer you might not
like it you might think
elsewhere jesus said yeah oh jerusalem
jerusalem or often i would have gathered
you as a hen gathers a chicks under his
wings you would not
your house is forsaken and desolate okay
now
what verse is that uh chapters tim
matthew
okay what's that got to do with is is it
in the same chapter that's what jesus
said about jerusalem yes
jesus said oh yes did jesus yes because
the fig tree was it was a parable what
jesus was saying it was like an active
parable okay
look he came to look at the tree and
there was no fruit on the tree
jesus came to the nation of israel there
was no fruit from the nation of israel
but what do you do jesus said brother
i've rejected you gave me a verse
that's you're saying to me i asked you a
question you're going to another chapter
and you're saying to me but i'm saying
to you why you're connecting i'm saying
the evidence elsewhere
that that message was indeed the message
of jesus it wasn't because he said very
clearly elsewhere
jesus said specifically of jerusalem
yeah your house is forsaken and desolate
okay but how could you relate that with
the fig tree when they're hungry and
they're going to a fig tree to eat and
they realize that i told you
it was a parable but that's what you're
seeing this is what i'm saying
what chapter is it let's look if jesus
is saying that right do you know what
chapter is
i don't know okay okay i want to look
into that yeah
see you've got to understand a lot of
things jesus said had a lot of deeper
meaning
he wasn't just going along and saying oh
i'm hungry let's have some food oh
there's no fruit there i'll curse this
tree no no no because because what the
problem is
he didn't know if he is god if he knew
it's not the season for the fig tree why
would he go there
why would he go and then curse the tree
okay i'm telling you
i'm telling you no okay no no no i'm
telling you
i'm telling you so he wasn't good he
used his man brain
it was god living as a man he was god
okay
how does that work how could god that
created everything doesn't know that the
fig
is not the season for the future he gave
up the power to know he lived as a man
subject to the holy spirit that's how he
knew it okay okay that's your answer but
that's not my answer oh so you're
different you you yes
oh you differentiate my answer
well i mean what he's saying is what
he's saying is not
that's that's a big differentiation well
what he's saying what he's saying
what he said is true
yeah but i just think on this particular
occasion when jesus cursed the fig tree
it wasn't because he didn't know there
wasn't going to be any fruit on it okay
what he was saying is
i have come from heaven to earth to the
nation of israel
okay okay i've looked for fruit okay
from the nation of israel okay
there is no fruit here that's in matthew
this is in mark can i read mark
okay this is what it says okay the next
morning as they were leaving bethany
jesus was hungry okay he noticed a fig
tree okay if he's talking about the
nation of israel
jesus shouldn't be hungry to go to the
fig tree because he should be like you
know what guys
we're going to go to the fig tree and
i'm going to give you a parable about
the israelis
yeah the israelites right but he doesn't
know he goes i'm hungry and he goes whoa
there's a fig tree there
let's go and eat right this is this is
not my word this is what it says
he noticed a fig tree in full leaf a
little way off
so we went over to see if he could find
any figs he doesn't say i wanted to find
any israelis he said i went there to
find anything which you are not into
you're agreeing
i think you're a muslim bro we're going
together here okay
okay no i don't know anyway but there
were only leaves because it was too
early in season
listen this is not my word this is not
sid's word this is the bible it clearly
says that it was
not the season now what we need to ask
our christian brothers is
if it if it wasn't this season and if
jesus is god
if he wasn't me a man who said you know
what okay he was a man a man can make a
mistake but they go he's god he's the
creator of that fig tree
he goes to the fig tree and goes oh
there's no figs
can you imagine god almighty go into the
fig and saying
oh there's nothing sorry guys i i made a
mistake i didn't know my creation
what we're doing is we're questioning
about sid is saying he's talking about
the israelites as
with the bad um given that but over here
it doesn't say that's it so you need to
explain to us
well all i'm saying is mark himself
yeah may not have understood what jesus
was getting at frequently
frequently the israelites didn't
understand what's so mark
mark should know all right if mark
should know and this is mark or peyton
or peter because
we believe mark got his information no
problem then why did a mark like that
done and say you know what he may not
have understood
sometimes that's what it says didn't
understand what he was getting at okay
but i said listen to me listen i didn't
understand what was going on
okay if i'm inspired by the effects if
mark is inspired by god
you're saying he didn't know no we don't
we don't we don't
claim that the gospel writers everything
that they wrote was perfect okay they
have perfect understanding okay
when you say inspired by god that means
god speaks to them
right okay are you telling me god told
him something wrong to write
no we're not saying that i don't
understand he's inspired by good we're
saying
mark faithfully yeah sought to write
down
what he heard jesus saying nice an
accurate record of what took place was
mark inspired by good
mark had inspiration but he was not
perfect okay there's no claims
no one claims when it comes to god god
will not mess around with this
thing mark's special life where he wants
to go and hunt for dears
that's not a problem you can make a
mistake there but who's mark inspired by
god
very penetrating by inspiring inspired
like you guys think he was inspired god
spoke to him and he started writing
no we don't claim that he was you don't
think the words were dictated by god no
absolutely
so how does that okay so mark wrote it
by his own head
mark wrote down what he believed a fatal
record of what jesus said and did
i do believe what jesus said so he
wasn't inspired he thought
what jesus said and did was perfect okay
no no
i respect mark's record isn't perfect so
mark wasn't inspired right
what are you doing by inspiring because
no not perfect all right i'm not saying
the record
is perfect i know i know can we fault in
the record did the holy spirit speak to
mark
to you know inspire him to write jesus
the holy spirit speaks to me
[Music]
fight them until persecution is no more
look that's
fight did you hear that so persecution
is no more and religion is for allah
did you hear and then and then look what
it says say if they cease then allah
sees what they do